Thomas is with us in Texas hi Thomas how
are you I'm doing great Dave how you
better than I deserve what's up well I
just want to tell you personal life and
I a long time SVU
facilitators we've been to on trade
leadership there in Nashville at your
place and we've also we'd put our church
through it as well as led them through
it so thank you and thank you and God
for all your blessings well thank you
sir
thank you for all the help how can I
help you today well my wife and I I'm 59
6:52 we just recently paid off 27 acres
and a barn that we had built you know 10
12 years ago and a house we've been into
for five years now where we are it's
about five hundred fifty thousand dollar
house we've paid off then we got about
two hundred sixty left on it we're
getting after trying to get it done good
good where you expect to pay that off we
make to sixty year Wow we expect to pay
that off within the next few years but
here's the thing
I'm very desirous to put a 100 percent
solar power system on our property here
and they'll cover 100% of our electric
electrical needs
okay and the thing is other than our
emergency fund our fully funded
emergency fund we don't have the cash to
do it it's going to be we tell you the
reason I'm under the gun it's a time
crunch and it's this first of all the
federal tax incentives are going away
last year they were 30 this year they're
phasing down to 26 next year 22 and then
they're gone
yeah but that's not the problem because
we could save up through the year and do
it this year but right now I have a
quote from an installer who's going to
give me an additional thirteen thousand
dollars for a you know if I just pay it
off and and bites on him now but I'm on
a time limit within the next month to
get that done if it okay to borrow
against the house and tack that under
the note and put that in okay
this is the same guy who said he'd Leeds
Financial Peace University right you
know what I'm giving you a hard time you
know you know I'm not gonna ever tell
someone to borrow money I know that you
don't borrow money and I tell people in
the never borrow money except the
possibility on a purchase of a home and
that's it
I have never in the history of the show
or the history of financial abuse
University told somebody to borrow money
for solar and I wouldn't do it in a
fantasy world I wouldn't do it's not
fantasy where my fantasy world you make
to our sixty thousand dollars a year
you got a Salesman painted you into a
corner and holding a gun to your face
time to jump in the creek and eat his
13,000 and if he doesn't come back with
a $13,000 discount when you got the
money to pay cash he'll do business with
his freakin competitor okay no pay cash
you make two hundred and something
thousand dollars you turn sixty thousand
a year how much this project cost the
total price of it is $82,000 yeah okay
with and you get a tax credit for twenty
six percent of that this year yeah and
you can pay cash for that this year
can't you yes give you the thirteen
thousand in the fall or I'll go to his
competitor that's just bull yeah that's
just bull you know if he doesn't want to
do it it's okay somebody will take my
money if see you tell you how many solar
projects are eighty two thousand on a
residential piece of property
none this is the biggest fish this guy's
ever gotten on a hook in his life he
ain't gonna let you off you're holding
the game you got all the Aces baby he
don't have any you're holding the car
right so you play this you're the guy
making 260 you're the guys got money
he's a solar salesman now last question
right what do you think the break-even
period is on this how much when you save
on your electricity bill how much are
you gonna save how long stake you get
your eighty two thousand back Oh will be
a long time but actual would be about
sixty nine thousand that to the credit
okay but
you know and after the 13 and all that
okay so anyway $60 a long time I won't
it it won't be as long as I'm going to
be paying electric bill and wasn't just
because their electric bill anyway it's
also stewardship of the planet and
security yeah I got you I've having
electricity when nobody else does I
appreciate all that those two things are
luxuries the financial decision is the
break-even okay right so how much are
you going to save a year in money on
electricity mmm well again not counting
the increase in electrical cost anything
like that in the coming 12 months after
you install it right now right about
four thousand bucks a year okay so ten
years you make 40 grand but your
breakeven your breakevens 15 years not
counting increases in electric bill so
your breakevens probably between eight
and twelve years something like that
I believe in solar the solar
technologies that are out there now are
vastly superior to what they were even
just a decade ago but certainly when it
all started coming out when you and I
first started seeing it twenty and
thirty years ago it was crap but the
technology is amazing now and it's worth
it I endorse or I endorse solar
companies for installs in a lot of
markets but I would not recommend on a
financial basis that you do an
eight-year break-even period or a
ten-year break-even period that's too
long but here's what I would do if I
were in your shoes okay I would do the
deal I pay cash for it huh but in my
mind I would say half of this is because
I have two hundred sixty thousand dollar
income and I can just afford to burn
thirty thousand dollars and this is how
I want to burn it it's a luxury purchase
it's going on a thirty thousand ended
okay and the other thirty thousand is a
reasonable the other thirty thousand is
a reasonable financial decision okay
yeah I don't want you to call this a
financial decision because it's not you
know it's like if you put a pool in the
backyard for $25,000 and the value of
your house goes up ten thousand well you
got to enjoy fifteen thousand worth of
the
because the other part of it doesn't
make sense right and that's what this is
you're got you get you got a bee in your
bonnet about solar and you know you can
afford to write a check and do this
thing by the end of the year and you
should write a check in cash by the end
of year and do this thing I may not be
doing with this particular company
because I'm already pissed off at this
company but but you know the good news
is dude you've done very well with money
you're very wise you make a lot of money
you've been very intentional but you got
solar panel fever
I mean don't don't jump off the dadgum
cliff now man let's just say portion of
this is just because I can and a portion
of this makes financial sense and that's
okay it's like putting a pool in the
backyard
same thing other people rather that
would pool but that's okay again I'm not
against solar usually in most areas of
the country depending on how where the
Sun is and all that kind of stuff it'll
make more sense than the numbers you're
giving me but you're doing it for other
reasons here and I get that I'm with you
hey thank you for the call and thank you
for leading Financial Peace University
and don't ever tell anybody one of those
classes to borrow money to buy solar
panels I'll come hunt you down